so yes you set out to see if there was a
green industrial future for Scotland and
you've written a report you've got it
with you so what did you find well you
know the starting point to this I
actually published a report last year
about Scotland's green energy potential
and what we argued in that is that we
could increase our output five-fold what
this report does is take that on and
talks about how we build the supply
chain and I guess everything that's
happened since then that the war in
Ukraine that's taking place the desire
for energy security so there's a real
race you can see in North America you
can see in Europe and we've got to make
sure that Scotland is in the right place
to benefit from that we'll be about five
percent of the global offshore wind
market so people don't have to come and
invest in Scotland we need to make sure
that they want to do that that we can
get the supply chain jobs we don't make
the mistakes if I may say so that we
made with oil and gas that we get the
full benefit of this and I think there
are some encouraging signs already we've
seen the investment by Sumitomo in a
cabling manufacturing facility in the
highlands but we need more of that and
what we're saying to the Scottish go
government is that we need to work
collaboratively with those in industry
but those in Academia make sure we're
driving The Innovation get the key
people around the table and the first
minister to host a strategic Industrial
Council you know when I when I look in
the rear view mirror and I've referenced
a book by a chap called Anderson that
shows that Scotland has lost relative
population share every decade in the UK
since the 1850s we have to change the
record we have to show that we're
serious about sustainable economic
growth green energy transforms our
ability to grow and it's about how we
deliver on that how we also benefit from
our academic Excellence which is the
other theme which is contained within
the report okay so people will want to
know what a green energy feature means
for North Sea oil we've seen labor
mooting plans on to ban new expiration
do you agree with that I think what we
need to do is actually show people we
have a proper roadmap Anna and of course
oil and gas is an important part of the
the mix over the course of the short
what we need to do is look at the demand
side of things and we need to look at
how we ramp up green energy production I
mean I've talked about that five-fold
increase by 2050. if we can if we can
decarbonize our economy we will reduce
our dependency and oil and gas and
that's really the question that we need
to ask and then it's a question of what
is the outturn in oil and gas production
we need to make sure that we transition
effectively we've got a lot of jobs in
oil and gas 70 odd thousand in the
energy report that I published last year
we talked about getting to 325 000 jobs
in Green energy so it's about that
transition and how we actually over that
Journey we reduce our dependency in oil
but it remains a key part of the mix of
over the short and medium term reducing
your dependency on North Sea oil is that
a tacit admission that Independence is
not looking like it's on the cards
certainly in the short term given that
the the money from nausea oil was always
again keep part of the economic plan for
Independence look at the end of the day
I think there's a there's that question
about what happened to the Bounty from
nausea oil there was 350 billion of tax
receipts and where has it gone what
we're trying to do in this paper is to
make sure that we can deliver that
sustainable economic growth in Scotland
that we can get the investment we can
drive up productivity we can get the tax
receipts and I think through that give
confidence to people in Scotland that we
have got the vision as to what an
economy of an independent Scotland will
look like and in some respects I would
turn this around and say when is the
industrial strategy for the UK it
doesn't exist he does an effective plan
and it's multifaceted you can talk about
offshore winds I want to see a plan for
tidal for example and I'm calling on the
UK government because it has reserved
powers to make sure we support that
industry let's get the investment in
carbon capture and storage you know one
of the things I talked about if I made
just briefly in Academia we bring lots
of students over to Scotland we train
them we educate them and then we ask
them to go home that's clearly insanity
we won't need to make sure that we've
got the talent that can help Drive our
economy and we need to have an effective
post-study work visa so there's so many
things that we can do take the right
decisions that will allow us to deliver
economic growth okay and I'm sure that
the government will be uh pouring over
your report in the meantime though
you've announced you're stepping down at
the next election six other SNP MPS have
actually followed you in making the same
decision is this a crisis for the SMP no
it's not and I think hopefully you can
see this morning the enthusiasm I have
for this I want to make sure although
I'm not going to be an MP I'm still
playing a part I want to support the
first Minister and the delivery of his
economic plans because that's that's
what it will be you know I've been in
the SNP since the 1970s and I want to
make sure and they're not too dim and
distant future that we finish that
journey to Independence and while I may
not be an MP I'm still certainly going
to be playing my full part in that your
colleague Murray black said she was
stepping down as an MP partly because of
what she described as a toxic working
environment you've obviously worked at
Westminster as well do you recognize
what she said I think it's been a
challenging period everything that we've
gone through brexit in particular in the
whole atmosphere in the place we need to
make sure that people can come to
Westminster can do their job they can do
that with respect and Trust across the
place and it you know I'd say it's quite
sad that we're using losing people of
young people effectively of of talent
such as Maddie we need to make sure that
Parliament can be a place that's
welcoming to people and they can show
their towns to the fullest extent and as
you leave I wonder if you can reflect on
some of the rules in Westminster because
today our Westminster accounts is
looking at second jobs for energy so
we're going to take a look at yours
um all in the public domain these um
these figures and of course all
completely within the rules but you have
um done 31 hours of work in this current
Parliament at an average of 1 200 pounds
per hour do you think the rules are
appropriate well Anna when I came into
Parliament I had two non-executive
directorships two chairmanships and I
said at the last election that I would
wind those up and I did that very very
very early in this Parliament I think it
was done by the by the end of the first
quarter of that Parliament so these were
these were kind of Legacy issues if you
if you like there is I think a
legitimate debate about earnings of of
MPS I've actually just gone on to the
committee of standards and public life
and I'm sure all of these things that we
will we will reflect on because I think
it is important that the the public can
have trust in those that they they send
to Parliament well yes and and what we
found is that MPS were second jobs have
an average wage of 233 pounds per hour
that's 17 times the national average
yeah do you think that will sit
comfortably with people you know you've
seen obviously the likes of Boris
Johnson this trust Aaron eye-watering
sums of money on the speaking circuit
benefiting from the position that they
had as as prime minister and I think
rightly people were appalled that that
kind of behavior I think it's important
that we can trust our our politicians
and I think people have to look very
carefully at what they do being an MP is
a very important job it is a full-time
job
of course at the end of the day you're
you're accountable to your electric when
you stand in front of them at the in the
next election I think most MPS do work
very hard it is an all-consuming job but
yeah absolutely let's make sure that
there's food transparency in this that
people are not abusing the Privileges
that's put in them as as members of
parliament very quickly you mentioned
Boris Johnson what do you make of the
fact that his older phone is not being
handed over at the moment to the covert
inquiry we're told
it's I mean I find this extraordinary
that he can't remember the past the
passcode for his phone really
um you know I think we need to have that
feel transparency in in this inquiry and
I think it's important that these
messages are on that phone are
accessible to the inquiry okay in
Blackford thanks very much Lee for
coming in we appreciate your time this
morning my pleasure thank you